[Música]
Hola Esto es África 7 días el magazine
de la actualidad africana mi nombre
esman comenzamos con los titulares la
ofensiva de seducción de los
diplomáticos extranjeros continúa en el
continente africano el turno lo tiene
ahora microculeva ministro de asuntos
exteriores de Ucrania que recorrió el
continente en busca de apoyos esto
ocurre luego de que Rusia y occidente
emprendieran sendas giras por África el
ministro de asuntos exteriores ruso
también hace una nueva gira tras la
victoria del presidente Turco recep
erdogan en la segunda vuelta de las
elecciones presidenciales analizamos las
relaciones entre Turquía y África en los
últimos 20 años erdogan ha trabajado
para reforzar Los lazos diplomáticos y
económicos y militares de ankara con las
capitales del continente africano
Y por último pasamos al deporte y al
auge del baloncesto en África mariam
Connect nuestra corresponsal en la
capital ruandesa kigali siguió la
competición de la básquetbol africa link
está acontecimiento deportivo promovido
por la NBA se ha convertido en la cita
ineludible de los mejores equipos de
baloncesto africanos
[Música]
pero empecemos por la rivalidad entre
Rusia y Ucrania por ganarse Las Naciones
africanas esta vez es kiev quien ha
pasado a la ofensiva con la gira
continental de su jefe de la diplomacia
de microculeva durante su viaje culeva
visitó cuatro países africanos Marruecos
Etiopía Ruanda y mozambique su visita
Sigue a las de sus homólogos
estadounidense y Ruso en un momento en
que África se está convirtiendo en un
teatro de lucha por la influencia
geopolítica global
unos tras otros ucranianos y rusos
recorren el continente africano en busca
de apoyos entre tres giras del ministro
ruso de asuntos Exteriores
en el verano de 2022 el pasado febrero y
esta última semana de mayo su homólogo
ucraniano de microculeva quien visitó el
continente africano en octubre de 2022
acaba de completar una segunda gira su
misión contrarrestar la creciente
influencia de Rusia en África ya que
desde hace varios años o Moscú se
esfuerza por convertirse en el socio
privilegiado de África en adisa veva la
capital etíope quien esperó obtener
algún apoyo en un continente que
reivindica cierta neutralidad desde el
inicio de la invasión rusa
intentamos explicar a nuestros amigos
africanos que la neutralidad no es la
respuesta porque al permanecer neutrales
ante la agresión rusa contra Ucrania
están proyectando su neutralidad sobre
la violación de fronteras y los crímenes
masivos que pueden estar ocurriendo muy
cerca de casa o incluso con ustedes
[Música]
pero la tarea de culeva no es fácil en
febrero 22 de los 54 estados miembros de
la unión africana se abstuvieron o no
participaron en la votación sobre la
última resolución de la asamblea general
de la ONU que pedía Rusia que retirara
sus fuerzas de Ucrania dos países
eritrea y Mali Incluso votaron en contra
otro asunto en el que Ucrania ha
intentado recabar el apoyo africano es
la seguridad alimentaria
los precios del pan en África y Asia
dependen de un hecho muy simple cuánto
grano puede ser exportado de Ucrania al
año y si Rusia no hubiera invadido no
habríamos tenido este problema pero lo
tenemos ahora
aquí es donde decimos lucharemos en una
guerra ganaremos estamos seguros de ello
pero mientras tanto queremos reavivar
nuestras relaciones
culeva se mostró decidido a iniciar una
nueva era en las relaciones entre
Ucrania y África anunció la apertura de
nuevas embajadas en el continente y la
próxima organización de una primera
Cumbre Ucrania África una respuesta a la
segunda Cumbre Rusia África que se
celebrará a finales de Julio en San
Petersburgo
y tras la visita de culeva
musamat ex Primer Ministro de chat y
presidente de la comisión de la unión
africana advirtió contra la lucha entre
Ucrania y Rusia por la influencia en
África escuchamos
12 contexto internacional
de intereses geopolíticos divergentes la
voluntad de una u otra parte amenaza con
transformar África en un campo de
batalla geoestratégico
en este juego de suma Cero en el que las
ganancias de otros se traducen en
pérdidas para África debemos resistirnos
a toda forma de instrumentalización de
nuestros estados miembros
cambiamos de tema el presidente Turco
receptogana ha ganado la segunda vuelta
de las elecciones presidenciales África
siete días ha decidido echar una mirada
al activismo diplomático del hombre
fuerte de Turquía en África desde su
llegada al poder en 2003 erdogan se ha
esforzado por hacer de su país un socio
central en el continente y la influencia
de Turquía ha crecido considerablemente
en varios frentes el aumento del número
de embajadas es muy revelador como se
puede ver en este gráfico
las embajadas turcas han pasado en
África de 9 en 2003 a 44 en 2023 en las
embajadas africanas en Turquía han
pasado de 12 en 2003 a 37 en 2023
veamos ahora esta cronología de los 20
años de acercamiento entre la Turquía de
erdogan y África
en 2005 erdogan declaró el año de África
mucho antes de que Beijing y París
hicieran lo mismo en 2006 y 2010
respectivamente la primera Cumbre
Turquía África se celebró en Estambul en
agosto de 2008 Y también fue ese año
cuando la unión africana declaró a
Turquía socio estratégico en 2010
Gracias al apoyo de los países africanos
Turquía fue elegida por primera vez
miembro no permanente del Consejo de
Seguridad de la ONU en 2014 la segunda
Cumbre Turquía África fue celebrada en
malabo capital de Guinea ecuatorial
mientras que la tercera Cumbre Turquía
África tuvo lugar en Estambul en
diciembre de 2021
por tanto Turquía tiene una presencia
muy fuerte en África no solo
diplomáticas sino también económica y
militar la mayoría de los países del
continente tienen vuelos directos con
Turquía y varios países entre ellos
Egipto Libia Nigeria y Ruanda importan
armas de Turquía que también tiene bases
militares en Libia y Etiopía Por último
el comercio entre ambas partes también
crece rápidamente en construcción
energía y textiles decenas de empresas
turcas han invertido más de 78.000
millones de dólares en África antes de
cerrar con este tema señalamos que
durante sus dos décadas en el poder
erdogan ha sido el líder no africano que
más veces había visitado el continente
40 veces en 20 años
pasamos ahora a la actualidad deportiva
la básquetbol África League nació hace
tres años y desde entonces se ha
convertido en la competición de
baloncesto más importante de África
promovida por la NBA permite a los dos
doce mejores equipos africanos competir
en las mismas condiciones que en Estados
Unidos
retransmitida en más de 200 países la
básquetbol africa League ha cambiado la
faz de este deporte en África este año
la fase final de la competición tuvo
lugar en la capital ruandesa Marian con
nuestra corresponsal la siguió para
nosotros después de Egipto y senegal fue
finalmente en uruanda en que Gali donde
los mejores equipos de baloncesto
africano se reunieron para disputar la
fase final de esta competición la
básquetbol african League ya que decir
que se trata de la competición de
baloncesto por excelencia en el
continente africano creada en 2019
en tan solo tres años esta competición
se ha consolidado en un tiempo récord
como parte indispensable del panorama
africano hasta el punto de hacer más
atractivo el baloncesto africano y
animar los jugadores africanos a querer
quedarse en el continente
es una competición patrocinada por la
NBA Así que nos va a haber mucha gente
es una oportunidad para mí y para mis
compañeros porque quizás haya jugadores
que no tengan necesariamente mucha
exposición Y esta es una oportunidad
real para los africanos y para otros
jugadores de tener oportunidades
profesionales interesantes
pero los jugadores africanos no son los
únicos que quedan ya que muchos
occidentales sobre todo jugadores de la
NBA están abandonado Estados Unidos
conocido como la Meca del baloncesto
para unirse a los equipos africanos
durante esta
que me ha ofrecido un contrato muy
interesante desde el punto de vista
económico y también porque creo que
tengo lo que hay que tener cada vez hay
más jugadores que vienen a equipos
africanos porque cada vez nos ofrecen
mejores condiciones la próxima temporada
de la básquetbol african League está
prevista por mayo de 2024 esta cuarta
temporada Podría tener lugar una capital
africana distinta de que Gali así
cerramos este capítulo de África siete
días y los dejamos con imágenes de la
básquetbol africa League gracias por su
sintonía a la actualidad internacional
continúa en trans24
[Música]